packed with cooking tips information and
100 recipes to stake your life on
right put your feet up for my perfect tv
dinners
[Music]
like all chefs good food is my life and
for me tv dinners are all about recipes
that are fuss-free quick and easy to
make so however busy you are you can
always knock up brilliant food
my tv dinners need minimum shopping and
rely on the staple ingredients you
already have in the cupboard so you can
enjoy incredible dishes
whenever you want
starting with my delicious mushroom and
leek pasta
this fantastic fast and simple pasta
dish made with everyday ingredients just
goes to prove you can eat good food
whenever you want
really important put the water on first
so you can just have it gently simmering
away ready for the pasta
while the water comes to the boil start
the sauce by slicing mushrooms first off
fingers one in front two behind
up and down
then add olive oil to a hot frying pan
[Music]
i want that nice color on the mushrooms
off the heat literally 10 seconds
and when you toss something really
important you get all the ingredients at
the end of the pan
push down and pull back
that noise that
that's all the water coming out of the
mushrooms
next finely chop a fat clove of garlic
[Music]
then prepare your leeks
just take your knife
and go down
through the center turn it over
and again into quarters
so you've got all that opening up and
then just rinse the top of that to get
rid of any potential dirt or sand
it just breaks up into nice little
quarters
add
all that leak
into those mushrooms
beautiful
and now the secret is to get rid of that
water inside the leek
as it cooks down all the water's gone
you just left that really nice intense
flavor
garlic's got nice and crispy now we're
going to add a touch of chicken stock in
there
beautiful
lasagna sheets just gonna drop the
sheets
in to the water
lasana sheets are an unusual choice for
a dish like this but they work
brilliantly although any type of pasta
you've got in the cupboard will do
and just twist that pan
that stops any pasta actually sticking
to the bottom of the pan
chicken start to reduce down by half
and it's almost delays the bottom of the
pan basically washed all that wonderful
flavor off turn the gas down
and add a couple of tablespoons of cream
this just enriches the dish bring it
back up to the bowl and let it simmer
for three to four minutes
now
the secret with the pasta is just taking
it out a little early
so you've got that nice texture
hold up the sheet and just nip it
and you can feel your fingers in the
center it's ready turn the sauce down
and lay
these beautiful sheets
of lasagna into that sauce
i'm just gonna turn the gas off now
and let the pasta sit in there and
absorb that amazing sauce
finish with chopped fresh tarragon
it's a delicious herb it goes
brilliantly well mushrooms and leeks
just let that sit and almost sort of
infuse
to serve i'm making a quick bruschetta
by toasting fresh chipata bread two nice
slices drizzle that
in olive oil
a little bit of garlic
just rub the bread
the crust as well crust is what really
takes that garlic
now
pan for the bread a little touch of
olive oil
as it starts to smoke
bread in
[Music]
but look at the pasta now it's been
stained by that amazing sauce to serve
on a nice spoon of my mushrooms leeks
and cream then i'll take my pasta
just twist it
and let it sit on top
that tarragon has just lifted everything
bread on
and that's the beauty about something so
simple they can be done in 20 minutes
with everyday ingredients a stunning
pasta dish
adding easy and versatile dishes like
this to your repertoire is what cooking
at home is all about so you can always
make great tasting food at the drop of a
hat
with foolproof pasta recipes up your
sleeve you'll always be able to knock up
a fantastic lunch or supper
here are three more of my super fast
pasta dishes that are bursting with
flavor and cooking minutes
kicking off with farfalli with ricotta
pancetta and peas
[Music]
start by frying lardons in a large pan
these smoked chunks of bacon have a
delicious deep salty flavor that makes
them perfect with pasta
when the lavender start to brown add
finely chopped garlic and turn off the
heat
next add farfeli to boiling salted water
[Music]
named after the italian for butterflies
this bow tied shaped pasta has a large
surface area great for sticking to
sauces
just before the pasta is ready add
frozen peas to the boiling past the
water
then when the pasta and the peas are
cooked drain and add to the lardons and
the garlic
spooning creme fraiche
[Music]
and dot with lumps of creamy ricotta
cheese
[Music]
season
then serve
ready in just 12 minutes
farfeli with ricotta pancetta and peas
a delicious quick and easy supper that's
ready when you are
[Music]
my next pronto pasta dish
is taglitelli with quick sausage meat
bolognese
[Music]
first bowl dry taglitelli and salted
water these long thin ribbons of pasta
come curled up in less and take around
10 minutes to cook
then add olive oil to a hot pan
and fry finely chopped onion
thinly slice garlic
and sweat until soft
[Music]
next remove the meat from your sausages
by cutting open their skins and crumble
into the pan
fennel or sicilian sausages are perfect
for this dish but any flavour sausage
will do
when the meat has browned add half
cherry tomatoes
season
[Music]
and add a few spoonfuls of the pasta
cooking water as the starch thickens the
sauce and helps it stick to the pasta
drain the teglatelli and add to the
sausage meat sauce
[Music]
finish with freshly grated parmesan
[Music]
perfect when you're really busy but
still want great tasting food fast my
amazing taglitelli with quick sausage
meat bolognese
[Applause]
my final pasta dish that's ready in a
flash and packs a real flavor punch
a spaghetti with chili sardines and
oregano
[Music]
first for the crunchy topping heat olive
oil in a frying pan
add chopped garlic
and breadcrumbs
[Music]
cook over medium heat until the
breadcrumbs are golden
season
and drain on kitchen paper
for the sauce add the oil from your
sardines to a hot pan
fry finely diced chili
and chopped garlic
next cook dry spaghetti in boiling water
then chop tin sardines into chunks
and add to the chili and garlic
tin sardines are a brilliantly versatile
ingredient to have in your cupboard
packed with protein full of super
healthy omega-3 oils and delicious
next drain your pasta and combine with
the sardine chili and garlic mixture
add leaves of fresh oregano
and mix in handfuls of rocket
to serve pile high and top with the
crispy garlic breadcrumbs
[Music]
ready in under 15 minutes spaghetti with
chili sardines and oregano healthy
hearty and full of flavor perfect pasta
in moments
[Applause]
whether you're rushing to put your feet
up in front of the telly and need
something fast and tasty for the family
or simply want something delicious to
enjoy these are three amazing pasta
recipes you can learn by heart and cook
in minutes
beautiful
[Music]
now here are five more of my essential
cooking tips starting with how to cook
an ingredient that's perfect for a quick
and easy tv dinner chicken breasts
this has to be the most popular part of
the chicken now it's very versatile
incredibly tender very lean hardly any
fat whatsoever the secret is cooking it
without it becoming dry
the first thing is to season it properly
both sides
two tablespoons of olive oil
get the pan nice and hot
the secret now
is to get a really nice color on the
skin
really nice color
no color no flavor skin side down
tilt the pan so it cooks the back of the
chicken breast where it's really nice
and round and very fat
let the pan do the work
chicken breast normally takes between
sort of 10 and 12 minutes to cook
properly
now we've got the color on the skin the
skin's nice and crispy we're going to
deglaze the pan
deglaze with masala
now masala has a sweet fortified italian
wine you can also use white wine
masala in
flambe
burn off the alcohol which gets rid of
that really sort of harsh alcoholic
flavor
roll the chicken around the masala
the glaze in the pan basically means
washing the pan
and lifting off all that flavor stuck to
the bottom of the frying pan and put it
into the sauce
now chicken stock
bring that up to the boil and let it
simmer for three to four minutes
[Music]
it's really important to leave the
chicken breast skin side up the skin's
nice and crispy and it's important now
the chicken cooks from underneath as it
starts cooking it absorbs the stock so
in the center of the chicken stays nice
and moist
[Music]
now the stock of the masala is reduced
down you can have the confidence to
allow it to almost disappear
and look
the combination between the masala and
the chicken stock is quite sweet so it
finishes the chicken with this really
nice delicious glaze on top
and there you go a delicious succulent
chicken breast with the most amazing
flavoursome skin phenomenal
soups make stunningly simple meals my
tip for adding incredible depth of
flavor is to always keep your leftover
parmesan rinds store them in the freezer
then add to the pan as the soup cooks
and leaves to infuse then remove before
serving is less waste and more taste
another tip to take homemade soup to the
next level whisk in cubes of cold butter
just before serving to get a glossy
velvety texture and a beautifully rich
taste
another fantastic standard for a
frost-free weekend eat is the classic
baked potato
my tip for a great crispy skin is to use
salt to your advantage simply add it to
the outside before cooking and the salt
will draw out the moisture in the oven
as it bakes
a touch of salt gives you an amazingly
crisp skin on chicken and fish too as
well as highlighting the flavor
[Music]
roasted nuts make a delicious tv snack
my tip for peeling them with these is to
simply toast them in the oven for about
10 minutes wrap in a tea towel and rub
until the skins are removed
perfect sprinkle with sea salt and so
with a glass of wine
this is my ultimate cookery course 100
recipes to stake your life on
coming up i'll be showing you my amazing
sweet corn fritters
that is such a delicious recipe
but first the key to whipping up my
ultimate tv dinners is having a
well-stocked store covered and even with
the basics like tin sardines tomatoes
pasta or rice it always pays to know how
to buy the best
next up my shopping guide to all things
pasta
when it comes to the sacred italian
staple you'll be hard-pressed to find
anyone who knows more than pastor
supremo antonio sakamani
pasta so much i have to eat it at least
once a day
he's been selling perfect pasta in
london soho for over 35 years and eating
great pasta for a lifetime
we'll make the best place in the world
italy
takes away the past in italy and the
people died you know and that's it
for a good very good pasta you need two
ingredients you need a good egg and very
good flour and that's it this is a durum
wheat flour look at that it's so soft
does it cook so quick couple minutes in
a boiling water this thin like this
couple minutes it's good
this shop is not it's not big enough to
store all the type of pasta this is the
famous uh spaghetto albronzo this is
penne
different shape is called fujili
antonio's right there's a mind-blowing
array of incredible pasta types that are
great to keep in your store cupboard
here's my quick guide to some of the
different shapes and sizes and how to
use them
small shapes like farfallini are perfect
for making simple stews and soups more
substantial and add an extra texture to
dishes like the classic italian pasta
soup minestrone
short tubes like penne are great for
thick cream or tomato based sauces as
the rigid edges hold more sauce for an
incredibly flavored packed mouthful
long and thin like the store cupboard
essential spaghetti the classic shape
was invented in naples but every italian
region has his own spaghetti dish from
bolognese to carbonara or my favorite a
lavongerle which is spaghetti with
delicious steamed clams
flat noodles shaped strands like
fettuccine are perfect with a simple
drizzle of olive oil or in rich buttery
dishes as a little sauce goes a long way
coating the pasta evenly stopping the
strands from sticking together
then pass the sheets not just great for
lasagnas but amazing rolled into tubes
and filled to make delicious cannelloni
or used in quick supper dishes like my
mushroom and leek pasta
finally speciality pastas like this
spaghetti made with squid ink has
delicately sweet taste and an amazing
jet black colour great for when you want
a delicious dinner that's a little bit
different
whatever shape you go for always look
out for the pastas that have been bronze
cut it means the dough was pressed
through a bronze cutting dye which has a
subtle rough texture which helps the
sauce stick as well as all the dried
types pasta also comes fresh which is
brilliant for tv dinners because it
cooks super quick and tastes incredible
too
in this shop we make pasta every day
look at that that's beautiful
it's sad to eat it this pasta is really
really yellow because we use good
quality of eggs you can
smell the eggs they come through
it's so good so fresh you can even
eat it raw like that
it lasts in the fridge two or three days
you can even freeze it and you want
chain taste whether fresh or dried pasta
so versatile and quick to cook is the
perfect tv dinner so go out stock up on
new shaves and you'll soon be turning
out dishes that would make pasta pro
antonio very proud it looks so nice so
good so healthy
you know and that's it can resist
we all lead busy lives but that doesn't
mean you have to compromise when it
comes to cooking great food
for me the secret is having recipes you
can depend on and a store covered full
of staple ingredients that can be
transformed into quick delicious dinners
on demand
so shop smart stock up and whether
you're feeding 2 or 20 you'll always be
ready to cook up something incredible
my next tasty dish uses simple and cheap
store cupboard ingredients with stunning
results and takes minutes to make
sweet corn fritters and yogurt dip
it's brilliant to have a number of great
recipes up your sleeve to rely on and
let's be honest we've all got a tin of
sweetcorn somewhere so i'm going to show
you how to make the most amazing fritter
[Music]
first off the mixture
take your flour sieve
really important to sieve the flour that
stops the mixture from having any lumps
in there
just before you get to the end
i want to put
half a teaspoon of baking powder the
baking powder gives the mixture some
lift
in
and just sieve that
through a touch of salt
and pepper
next an egg
about four tablespoons of milk
and give that a little
whisk now just put a little drizzle
of olive oil in there that helps to
relax the mixture
whisk that in make sure we got rid of
all those lumps
so that i want a nice smooth
almost like a cake mixture okay next
take the seeds out of a chili to lower
the heat roll the chili so give it a
really good
shake
[Music]
tap them out
slice
in half
into quarter
and each quarter
in half
and chop through
it's a really nice quick way
of slicing a chili
into the mixture spring onion
take off that outside layer of the
spring onion top and tail slice it in an
angle
it's a little bit of texture running
through the mixture i want that nice
crunch
in coriander
just slice through
nice and gently
and get that in there
next to the sweetcorn now drain it from
the tin and just pat it dry so it
doesn't make the mixture too wet
give that a nice mix
you can see now i've got two thirds
ingredients
and one third of the mixture to bind
together that's the secret of good
frittata so you're
you're biting into excitement and not
sort of dough
pan on
olive oil in
nice and hot
get a nice big dessert spoon you know
there's one nice portion
in
space the fritters evenly around the pan
in a clockwise direction so you always
know which one to turn first
just with the back of your spoon sort of
spread them out a little bit
okay
palette knife
just check
happy with the color
and turn over
beautiful
now for the chili yogurt dressing
deseed and finely chop a red chili
and add to a pot of natural yogurt
[Music]
and then some fresh lime
[Music]
finish with chopped coriander
coriander in
and give that a nice mix up
that chili just lifts it
the lime gives it that nice tanginess
the fritters
they smell amazing and with the sauce
it tastes fantastic
that is such a delicious recipe using a
tin of sweet corn from your cupboard
amazing
[Music]
follow my ultimate cookery course
bursting with valuable lessons
top tips
and 100 recipes to stake your life on
and you'll literally be cooking yourself
into a better chef
many of these amazing recipes are on my
app please check out the app store for
details
go on get cooking
packed with cooking tips information and
100 recipes to stay your life on
so sit back and enjoy my delicious
simple suppers
one of my essential mantras for becoming
a better cook is it's all about building
your confidence and the way to do that
is with practice
the key is to have a repertoire of easy
dishes you want to cook and eat time and
time again and soon you'll be on your
way to becoming a kitchen demon
my first dish keeps it simple but
delivers big time on flavor so it's sure
to become a regular quick supper fix
spicy tuna fish cakes
i love this recipe why
because it turns this humble ingredient
a can of tuna into something delicious
just
open up
and drain the tuna into a sieve
just lightly flake that
don't press it too hard otherwise you'll
dry out the tuna
now these are water chestnuts
just slice them nice and thin
you can buy them anywhere any
supermarket chestnuts and
fresh ginger
get rid of that rough skin on the
outside
by grating the ginger you get to get all
that really nice
sort of juice
in
take your spring onions and just slice
on an angle i like the texture of the
water chestnut
with a spring onion
or touch of fresh coriander
lovely next remove the seeds from a
chili to reduce its heat without losing
any flavor
and finely chop
chilies in
kaffir lime leaves
roll them up
nice and tight run your knife down the
center
once
and just chop
and that makes the fish cake nice and
fragrant
touch of salt
a touch of pepper
fish sauce
just lightly season
the tuna
to bind all those wonderful ingredients
two whole eggs
and give that a nice little whisk
and then
add your eggs get your hands in there
and start mixing
get the mixture
roll it hand to hand
and the palm pat them down nicely
to cook add a little ground oil to a hot
pan
at the face of a clock i'm going to go
from 12 all the way around
first one in
these fish cakes only take a few minutes
to cook so keeping track of the order
they go in the pan means you know which
one to turn first
[Music]
to the pan a nice gentle little shake
make sure that nothing's sticking to the
bottom
spatula
two fingers on top turn them over
beautiful that crackling noise is
something you always want because the
tune's already cooked so we just
lightly frying them to get a nice crisp
outside and gently
take them out
they smell
incredible
let them sit there we're gonna make a
really nice delicious simple dipping
sauce start off
a little pinch of sugar fish sauce two
tablespoons that gives it the saltiness
one tablespoon of rice wine vinegar
and some fresh lime juice
squeeze all that lime in there your
fresh coriander
lots of coriander and in
give that
a little mix
and then you have the most amazing spicy
tuna fish cakes who would have thought
something as delicious as that can come
out of the can
a simple supper in minutes that's so
mouth-wateringly easy and delicious
you're guaranteed to cook it again and
again
when it comes to simple cooking there
are two basic bits of kit i'm never
without that will save you time and
effort in the kitchen
a grater and a peeler the swivel peeler
a stainless steel one
absolutely incredible it's almost like a
lifesaver in the kitchen because they
are so quick so light swivel blade so
we've got so much more flexibility
actually go around the vegetable
and we call it speed peeler in the
professional kitchen because it does
literally
absolutely
rapidly peels your vegetables you have
minimal waste
good peelers cost them a couple of quid
and are great for everything from
peeling veg to finely slicing cheese and
making shards of chocolate a good
comfortable grip and a sharp stainless
steel blade ensures you'll always work
fast
[Music]
the box grater is another great
versatile kitchen tool and with its
planes for coarse grating fine grating
and super fine as well as blades for
slicing it's perfect for everything from
puring ginger and zesting lemons to
shredding onions super small so they can
caramelize in a flash and be sure to get
a solid handle to hold it firm
and it's got such volume inside it
doesn't crush everything up so i always
prefer to grate onto a tray or into a
bowl so you don't have to move it again
creating onto the board you've always
got to lift it up and place it in so
place the grater into a bowl and grate
two simple but essential speedy bits of
kit guaranteed to make your life in the
kitchen easier
[Music]
bread is a brilliant base for delicious
super fast lunches and suppers
here are three of my deliciously simple
recipes that transform a humble bit of
bread into a gastronomic treat
first up flatbreads with fennel and feta
add olive oil to a flatbread
[Music]
then place in a hot frying pan and toast
until crisp and golden on both sides
these deliciously versatile breads are
made without yeast and are available in
good supermarkets and local middle
eastern shops
next thinly slice fresh fennel
and scatter over the toasted flatbread
then toast aromatic fennel seeds in a
hot dry pan
and sprinkle on top
[Music]
crumble over wonderfully tangy feta
cheese
[Music]
finish with a drizzle of sweet and
sticky pomegranate molasses
bread transformed before your eyes
flatbreads with fennel and feta simple
delicious and ready to eat in minutes
my next recipe that turns a hunk of
bread into a stunning dish is bruschetta
with garlic tomatoes capers and pecorino
[Music]
start by slicing a baguette diagonally
to get a large surface area so it holds
more of the delicious topping
drizzle the bread with extra virgin
olive oil
then place it oil side down onto a
scorching hot griddle
when the bread is beautifully charred
remove and rub with a pill clove of
garlic paint attention to the edges
next half sweet cherry tomatoes and rub
the juices into the toasted garlic bread
then simply crush on top
[Music]
next slice and scatter over tangy caper
berries
and use a veg peeler to add shavings of
salty pecorino cheese
[Music]
finally drizzle with extra virgin olive
oil and add a twist of black pepper
fantastic fresh flavors in the flesh of
a griddle pan
toast has never tasted so good
[Music]
perfect for a simple light supper or an
easy lunch my next dish is the
cannellini bean crustini with anchovy
and olive oil
[Music]
first for the topping heat olive oil in
a frying pan
add tin cannellini beans along with the
juices
once heated gently mash the beans with a
fork
then add sliced black olives
roughly chop parsley
and a splash of sherry vinegar
season
and leave on a gentle heat
next half a festive batter
and splash with extra virgin olive oil
heat a griddle pan until smoking
and toast the bread all side down
pressing into the pan to char evenly
to serve
top the toasted chipatta with a canalini
bean mixture
and finish
with chopped anchovies
packed with bold flavors so easy you can
always make it blindfolded ready in
under 10 minutes but eaten in seconds
three different breads three fantastic
recipes
proof that even when you're pressed for
time you can still eat like a king
incredible welcome back to my ultimate
cookery course
[Music]
these are my perfect tv dinners
next up my guide to getting the best
ingredients for your money my shopping
manta is very simple first rely on your
senses make sure whatever you're buying
it looks smells and really feels good
and if you get the chance to taste it
before you buy it then do it
second is to recognize that knowledge is
absolutely crucial the more you know
about where your ingredients are from
and how they produce the better so don't
be scared ask lots of questions and
learn
and when you want a simple supper herbs
are perfect to use in your cooking they
add vibrancy an amazing depth of flavor
and once you get the hang of them they
are so quick and simple to use and one
woman who really knows these chef's best
friends is expert herb grower lorraine
melton
i love herbs i love the way you can cook
with them i love the smell of them
she's been growing an incredible array
of herbs in the wet cambridgeshire
countryside for over 20 years and can
smell a bay from a basil at 50 paces we
grow about 150 varieties of herbs it's
always interesting to grow new varieties
see what they taste like see what they
smell like it gets a bit addictive after
a while
broadly speaking you get harder herbs
and softer herbs softer herbs are things
like parsley basil rocket coriander
we grow two main types of parts so we've
got flat leaf parsley and curly parsley
flavour-wise i think they're very
similar although a lot of people would
say that the flat leaf parsley has got a
stronger more aromatic flavour this is
your common basil sweet genovese this is
a purple variety called ruben we do
greek basil thai basil holy basil when
you're looking for a basil you want a
bright fresh basil nice leaves no
blemishes and nice strong stems it's got
a lot of oils in it and it's very strong
smelling it just tastes a summer basil
lorraine certainly knows her stuff and
she's right soft herbs are delicate so
for maximum flavor always use them at
the end of cooking or simply add as they
are to cold dishes
here are my top five soft herbs that i
could never live without
[Music]
basil as lorraine said it comes in many
types all with an amazing sweet punch
and flavor great blitzed in pestos
sprinkled whole over mozzarella and
showing its versatility it even makes a
wonderful ice cream
parsley beautifully earthy and intensely
fresh use both the leaves and the stem
for great depth of flavor in savey
dressing soups and salads
coriander for an amazing hint of citrus
often used in thai dishes coriander is
perfect in curries and chutneys but it
bruises easily so treat it with care
tarragon a staple of french cooking this
has long soft green leaves and a
distinct anti-seed flavour great with
chicken or in rich creamy sauces
finally chervil both mild and sweet a
perfect pairing with fish an incredible
mix simply with melted butter for a
quick sauce those are my favorite soft
herbs what about the hard ones
the harder ones tend to be a more woody
plant
things like thyme rosemary you've got
your common time which is your ordinary
general bog standard cooking time and
then you've got things like lemon thyme
we do an orange thyme which is actually
one of my favorites it smells like thyme
but it's got a deep sort of musky scent
as well which is going to give you a
slightly different flavor in your dish
hard herbs like thyme can take more
intense cooking than soft herbs so
they're great in stews roast or pan
frying choose the right one and you can
add wonderful depth of flavor to your
dishes here are my top five i use day in
and day out
rosemary amazingly robust with great
bittersweet green leaves it's a classic
pad with lamb delicious sprinkled over
speciality breads like focaccia or great
as toppings for fruity sorbets
lorraine's favorite thyme a heady
aromatic pungent herb which adds
delicious flavor to a sunday roast it's
amazing with wild mushrooms and is
perfect in marinades
oregano warm and full of delicious
aromatic oils a staple of great italian
dishes and perfect sprinkled on pizzas
or in pasta sauces
[Music]
sage a strong tasting herb with a
deliciously bitter flavour incredible in
stuffings and with rich meats like pork
or duck
finally bay bitter sweet and spicy it's
delicious simmered in soups stocks and
risottos and just as good dried or fresh
grown herbs is a lot easier than people
think it is on winter boxes in balconies
and it's great you can just open your
window put your hand out and snip some
off
when you're out looking for hers make
sure they're nice and healthy no
blemishes stems look strong they should
just spring back it's a nice springy
sort of herbs smell obviously is quite
important not all things smell but
obviously if you think it's one that's
going to smell like lemon thyme you
should have a nice fresh lemon scent and
obviously the final one is taste you can
tip a bit off
and taste your herbs and you can see
what they taste like them
whether bored from a supermarket or pig
from your window box herb's a great way
to add fresh flavors to your dishes
perfect for delicious simple suppers
even if you got a super busy lifestyle
it doesn't mean missing out on delicious
desserts they just have to be simple to
make
when it comes to cooking at home
puddings should always be a pleasure and
never a chore and homemade puds are 100
guaranteed to impress
my next recipe has only two main
ingredients but simplicity doesn't mean
food can't taste out of this world
incredible griddle pineapple with spiced
caramel
if you're making a dessert for one or
two it's gonna be quick and easy this
sumptuous delicious griddle pineapple
fits the bill perfectly
pineapple a way of testing it's nice and
ripe
top of the leaves come out perfect ready
to go
always cut a pineapple with a serrated
edge knife
slice off the bottom
turn it back over
and slice the top part
now
keep that
for later
look at the core
the center of the pineapple and slice
down
directly in half
slice that in half
take each quarter and slice them
smells incredible
lay down flat and just slice
that core off
so you've got this perfect sort of boat
of pineapple
slice underneath
but stop
as you get
right at the end slicing around the skin
will make the pineapple easier to eat
but leaving it attached gives you more
control as it cooks
next heat a griddle pan as hot as you
can
start off
in the corner and push it down
so you really mark the pineapple
two minutes on each side
and then just
turn them
really nice color there look at that
beautiful
i'm gonna sprinkle them
with a little touch of sugar that's
gonna glaze them
now
slice the top
take out these beautiful glazed
slices of pineapple
next up the spiced caramel
now start off with your pan
nice and hot
sprinkle
four tablespoons of sugar in there
just flatten it
then add the seeds from a fresh vanilla
pod in
a small dusting of chinese fly spice
never stir caramel
let it sort of bubble and transform
here she goes
now i've got the colour i want it that's
the perfect color off with the gas
in with the butter and then
a couple of tablespoons of cream
lovely and then give that
a little whisk add the rest of your
cream
nice
and just
drip
that spicy caramel
over your pineapple
hmm
wow
simple elegant and seriously impressive
griddle pineapple with spiced caramel a
delicious treat all to yourself that
tastes even better shared
[Music]
next my tricks of the trade and kitchen
tips
first up the proper way to chop fresh
herbs to get maximum flavor
chopping herbs the secret is to chop
them not bruise them now basil
this is a soft herb so treat it with
some respect when people go mad chopping
herbs all the goodness comes out on the
board i want the goodness left inside
the basil place them all inside one
another with the largest
leaf at the bottom and it's almost like
rolling a cigar
large one at the bottom small ones in
the center
and then look place them down together
and just roll them
nice and gently don't bruise them
step one
rolled ready to slice
sharp knife imperative fingers
tucked in
the bottom part of your knuckle is the
guide between you and the herbs
that there
stops you from cutting your finger
really important to get comfortable with
a knife and just practice rolling the
knife across the board and relaxing that
wrist it's all in the wrist action so
herbs
up
fingernails tucked
underneath and just up and down
up and down
and there you have
a chopped basil that's not bruised
and smelling very fragra
right coriander so you get the bunch of
coriander hold it down
and just lightly shave
the leaves
off the stalks
bunch them up together and then just
again let the knife do the work take the
fingernails in and just chop once
and once only don't
hack it
just chop it you can always identify
when you bruise the herb when you've
removed the herbs off the board there's
a big green patch
mmm
full of flavour and none of the goodness
is left on the chopping board
a great tip for using leftover herbs
simply chop finely mix into butter roll
up in clim film and freeze
then when you want a herby hit cut into
slices and melt over steaks chicken or
veg
asparagus is great for a simple supper
to prepare always remove the lower woody
stem by gently bending and the asparagus
will snap at the perfect point
then boil or steam and serve with a
little of my herb butter
for a cracking soft boiled egg simply
place your egg in boiling water add a
splash of vinegar and cook for exactly
eight minutes
then plunge into ice water the vinegar
helps the shell peel off easily and the
ice water stops the egg from cooking
giving you the perfect runny yolk
[Music]
for fuss-free salad dressings simply add
the ingredients into a jam jar screw the
lid on tightly and shake to combine in
seconds there's no need to wash up a
whisk and the jar is ready made to store
any leftovers
follow my ultimate cookery course
bursting with valuable lessons
top tips
and 100 recipes to stake your life on
and you'll literally be cooking yourself
into a better chef
many of these amazing recipes are on my
app please check out the app store for
details go on get cooking
you